deutschland im grunde wir alle befinden
uns gerade im nirwana im niemandsland
zwischen zwei regierungen eine ist noch
nicht ganz da die andere noch nicht ganz
weg dabei gebe es so viel zu tun im
moment wir erleben nämlich gerade die
heftigste inflation seit 28 jahren die
energiepreise gehen durch die decke
benzin zum beispiel
ausgezeichneter jahrgang brennt nur
etwas im abgang jetzt muss man sagen
inflation ist natürlich ein wirklich
hoch komplexes problem mit vielen
ursachen die wirtschaft erholt sich
weltweit mehr nachfrage ergo höhere
preise die üblichen scheiß spielen am
ölhahn rom dann haben wir in deutschland
noch den sondereffekt durch die
vorübergehende senkung der
mehrwertsteuer lange rede kurzer sinn
meint eldh wird weniger so ist nicht nur
das benzin knapp 25 prozent teurer als
im vorjahr 21 prozent mehr müssen
verbraucher jetzt für heizöl hinlegen
und selbst das obst wird teurer ihr habt
vorteil erdbeeren halten sich viel
länger wenn es in der wohnung so kalt
ist wie im kühlschrank
gerade die lebensmittelpreise werden
noch zum echten problem der hartz iv
regelsatz sieht bei erwachsenen am tag
fünf euro und 19 für lebensmittel vor
weshalb man bald für eine einzelne
paprika und so weiter geht wird
kleiner tipp für ihren hochzeitstag
aber keine angst nächstes jahr gibt es
ja eine hartz-iv-erhöhung und zwar um
satte
0,76 prozent bei demnächst fast fünf
prozent inflationsrate finden sie den
fehler
essen wird überschätzt noch bedrohlicher
als das ist die sache mit dem heizen ja
es drohen gas und strom sparen das heißt
es muss irgendwas passieren man könnte
zum beispiel das wohngeld für haushalte
mit geringem einkommen tempo erhöhen
oder der staat könnte bei berufspendlern
zeitlich begrenzt auf einen teil der 99
cent steuern die pro liter benzin
anfallen verzichten aber das geht
scheinbar nicht
erstens weil das nicht geht
zum anderen gibt es ja auch darum mit
solchen instrumenten wie steuern und
abgaben eine gewisse lenkungswirkung zu
erzielen also wir wollen ja auch dass
die leute mehr in erneuerbare energien
investieren ja ja ganz wichtig ganz
wichtig wenn sie demnächst in ihrem
eigenen wohnzimmer frieren das soll so
ja
sie werden gelenkt weil sonst kaufen
sich ja ähnlich ein eigenes windrad
ja ich glaube ich würde sie mainz gut
aber das ist doch eher kontraproduktiv
für die akzeptanz der energiewende
man kann ja bei den klimazielen bleiben
und trotzdem noch mal temporär und
unbürokratisch helfen wie die franzosen
die deckeln bald den strom und gaspreis
auch italien gibt drei milliarden aus um
bestimmten haushalten zu helfen ist doch
super oder von italien lernen einst von
einem
hochschul schuldigen von einem
verdammten schulden des staates lernen
zu müssen und da habe ich keine lust
dazu
kein bock auf die verdammten pleite
makkaroni so
also bei ramsauer muss man langsam aber
mit der heimleitung sprechen oder
tatsache ist
italien handelt und wir diskutieren
derweil und vor allem diskutieren
bewährt schuld ist manche sagen der
putin ist schuld ja jetzt eine theorie
es
heißt er liefert uns zu wenig gas damit
nord stream 2 schneller an den start
geht andere sagen das völliger quatsch
hier könnte nicht gerd schröder bei
seinem kumpel putin für uns ein gutes
wort einlegen wieder hat keine zeit
[Musik]
gott mit etwas glück muss er das klavier
im winter verfeuern
vergaß kehrt tatsächlich zu den fakten
haben uns die russen immer pünktlich ihr
gas geliefert war immer so ist jetzt
noch so um dass deutschland noch so
abhängig ist von dem zeug das ist ja
unsere eigene schuld weil wir zu langsam
sind beim ausbau der regenerativen und
bei den stromnetzen stellen sich mal
eine sekunde vor wir hätten alle diese
aktivitäten schon vor zehn jahren
gestartet und es hätte vor zehn jahren
jemanden gegeben der gesagt hätte wir
müssen die stromnetze bauen mit
hochdruck er ist aber sofort dann werden
wir alles schon fertig wie stellen sie
sich das mal vor ich stelle mal vor wir
hätten als bundesregierung vor zehn
jahren einfach unsere arbeit gemacht wo
könnten wir heute stehen so gas wird
immer teurer wind und sonne zu langsam
ausgebaut was tun ich sage da ist
innovation gefragt in berlin wurde
gerade ein ja super spannendes start up
gegründet und zwar von zwei brüdern aus
neukölln die was richtig geiles erfunden
haben und zwar nennen die sich die cobra
dass ihr visionäres produkt heißt
schneiden sie an kohle regionale
fairtrade kohle direkt nach hause
geliefert zum heizen und kochen 100
prozent bio vegan und glutenfrei
erhältlich in den aromen vanilla
pumpkins preis und apfel sind viele aber
als investor bin ich aus
schön blöd maschmeyer
tatsächlich erlebt ausgerechnet die olle
kohl in diesem jahr eine renaissance
energiewende läuft winter ist coming die
inflation steigt reden wir drüber mit
dem heute show verbraucherschutzexperten
mit olaf schubert urlaub schön dass du
da bist wir haben drüber geredet gerade
beim erdgas sind wir zu abhängig von
russland was könnte man tun um den
ausbau von wind und sonne zu geschlossen
ja ich höre russisches erdgas muss ich
bin mir sicher wenn man mal genau suchen
würde dann würde man in russland auch
deutsches erdgas hinten drin
aber solange müssen wir uns halt
irgendwie anders kümmern und das
positive ist wir haben ja windenergie
ich habe es auch schon lange zu hause
geht einwandfrei als meine zwar bisschen
aus der steckdose aber ich habe dazu
keine vorhänge die kann ich zu ziehen
wir müssen die windkraftanlagen besser
nutzen ja dieses jahr war flaute und da
frage ich mich warum wird kein wind
importiert ja hier dustrie einfach ein
bisschen pustekuchen durch oder diese
ganzen solarkraftanlagen ja wahr werden
die nachts nicht umgeschaltet aufm und
energie und hier wird kohle propagiert
was ist aber mit mit dem guten sauberen
atomstrom von dem man gar nichts mehr
außer im iran heißt ja immer hier die
urananreicherung im urin ärgert die die
urananreicherung im iran
ihr wisst was ich meine also so lange so
lange muss sich der verbraucher selber
kümmere und eben die teure energie
intensiver nutzen ja also dass man eben
zb beim autofahren die abwärme dass man
die nutzt zum heizen in dem man eben
einfach durch die wohnung ja also durch
die bullen und heizt oder dass man
beim beim duschen irgendwie sich
parallel noch ein lauwarmer tee
aufgebrüht da muss der verbraucher
kreativ wie jetzt ist ja gerade im
supermarkt tatsächlich bei manchen
produkten relativ dramatisch und zwar
ausgerechnet bei den gesunden produkten
gemüse obst kartoffeln 16 prozent teurer
kopfsalat 34 prozent teurer wo soll das
alles noch hinführen ja also
kopfsalat ist wirklich hat also das ja
also wenn du kein geld mehr für
kopfsalat dann weiter dann musste das
dressing so laufen
das ist schwer ich denke natürlich das
problem ist wir sind halt abhängig vom
import ja werden sich mal so einen
gemüsestand angeschaut hat es gibt
gemüse und obst aus der ganzen welt ja
das einzige deutsche produkt weist dort
gefunden habe was china cool aber bevor
wir verhungern müssen wir glaube ich neu
denken und das fällt schwer wir müssen
gewisse dinge vielleicht auch wirklich
enttabuisieren ja
kannibalismus naja
ist die beziehung der hat ja immer so
ein bisschen so ein schmuddeliges image
also ist ja das hat ein geschmäckle
geradezu hingestellt
logisch da ist eben nicht vegan
aber wenn man wirklich mal konsequent
denkt also kannibalismus könnte zwei
probleme auf einmal lösen ja also hunger
und
jetzt kommen wir zu alldem auch noch die
weltweit kaputten lieferketten ich habe
diese woche gelesen ist droht ein
heiligabend einen ein weihnachten ohne
computer ohne spielekonsolen als
geschenke wird
2021 das traurigste weihnachten aller
zeiten oder
sind wir ehrlich also es ist so schön
wie letztes jahr als durch den segneten
schutz des corona die ruß die
verwandtschaft nicht kommen konnte
so schön wird es nie wieder mal nicht
wiederholen aber
aber bei bei spielkonsolen also da
beginnt die krücke zu hängen die wollen
alles haben hier ist sofort sofort also
ich habe auf meine erste spielkonsole
eigentlich 30 jahre gewartet haben und
ich meine man muss es immer so ein stück
plastik sein so ein sprödes nicht
nüchtern ist ja ich denke die
jugendlichen würden sich vielmehr freuen
über eine spielkonsole
die die eltern selber gebastelt haben ja
ja ja was aus rinde und moos und so also
so was kriegen meine kindern dieses jahr
also außer die frau die kriegt was
richtig edel etwas teures ein kopfsalat
denn geschlechtsverkehr hat man letztes
jahr
das kann nicht jedes weihnachten bringt
schon dass sich olaf schubert
so
aufnahme
hallo dies ist die automatische and cut
von oliver welke und der heute show
leider ist das video schon vorbei ihr
könnt den kanal allerdings gerne
abonnieren und ein weiteres video
anschauen vielen dank so müsse jetzt für
immer reich